joining us here on the Rich Eisen show a
man who spent eleven seasons with the
Philadelphia Eagles Wow 11 from 2006 to
2016 in his 14 seasons in the NFL is a
long snapper and now he is not only one
of the best magicians out there on the
market and entertainers but he's now an
author called life is Magic Meyer
inspiring journey from tragedy to
self-discovery Jon Dornbos courtesy of
John I love it thank you for having me
thanks for coming out this is rock star
man any time let's talk a little
football for your book the Eagles right
now appear to be a little bit lost at
five and six but there was no Laine
Johnson yesterday no Jordan Howard a
whole host of wide receivers what do you
think is going on with uh with Wentz in
the and the coaching staff and
everything going on in Philadelphia
right now best you can tell John I think
they're banged up and and when you have
injuries it's tough and then when you
start putting guys in and out of
position it's hard so you know you also
look at what Carson's doing out Carson's
banged up I mean the guy is unbelievable
night when I was in Philly I was
thinking about retiring I didn't really
know where I wanted to go and then they
offered me a three-year extension and I
remember sitting back saying okay if I
got a shot it's with Carson the guy's
got all the intangibles he's got the
height that got the strength he's got
the discipline he's got the smarts
they just got to bring it all together
he's got to chill out relax and to me
this is what it is ignore the outside
world just chill out go back to what you
do and keep it simple to me simple game
plans win like when we would go Sunday
to Thursday right we were like with Andy
Reid we were we would destroy people on
those Thursday games because everything
was simple just let guys go one on one
and win the battle yeah I mean in one of
their best wins this year was that early
game at Green Bay there you go the early
week game at Green Bay and that that is
basically their crown jewel of a win
that they've had so far this year
against against Green Bay come on I know
and in my opinion Green Bay is good
every year you got Aaron Rodgers man
you're good well they're at Miami next
and then their home for the Giants on a
Monday night then they're at Washington
so if you give them those teams together
have six wins so if you give them three
wins in those games they're sitting
there just maybe a game behind or even
Todd with Dallas going into that home
game against Dallas yeah there's still a
way out I know there's always a way out
I mean this is the NFL what I noticed is
here's the thing though good teams can't
lose to teams that aren't as good as
right you can't put down your opponents
so they got to come in they got to
destroy my um you got to go in you got a
hand to your business in New York and
then you got to hope that the Dallas and
the other NFC's teams maybe take it to a
tank on a game that you know maybe they
shouldn't while your perfect person
asked this because the conversation
about Dallas is all about what Jerry
Jones had to say after the loss in New
England yesterday and how they were not
as prepared or as coached well for the
circumstances of the game with the
weather and how special teams comes into
play and that special teams is 100%
about coaching what do you think about
that concept I I agree and I think it
goes back to a much simpler route of
this so you get guys out of college you
get first-round pick second third fourth
you get all-stars at college that now go
into the pros yes and some of those guys
aren't used to playing special teams but
really the reality is that's all they're
gonna do in the NFL right so you can't
assume that these guys that are amazing
athletes know how to play special teams
and know how to put their bodies and
positions to be successful in open space
so what I've learned is that the great
coaches that I've been able to play for
simplify it and they teach very simple
fundamentals like yeah for instance you
get a linebacker that's a stud in
college and all of a sudden he's
blocking a guy on the front row and
kickoff return that is a completely
different world and you're they're a six
round selection yeah man off of being a
big man on and and now they're asked to
do something that they've never done and
you can't assume that their athleticism
is gonna get them there so what I've
noticed is coaches that keep special
teams extremely simple coaches that
teach hard core fundamentals and
technique in the special teams game
those are the coaches that I've had
success with those are the coaches that
I've seen have success so who was who
was your special a lot Danny Smith John
Harbaugh I had Bobby Bobby April was a
guy that would go just to the
fundamentals now we're going back 10 15
years John Harbaugh that's right he was
the apples special teams coach got a
chance with the with the Ravens now look
at him and he's destroying it and what I
liked about Harbaugh is this is he was
tough I mean he literally the harder he
was on you the more you realized the
more he cared about you and the more he
thought you needed to succeed for you if
he ignored you that's when you're like
okay like he doesn't think you're gonna
hack it so when he was hard on me and
when he was hard on the guys around me
you got to internalize that take it as
constructive criticism and realize that
the harder these coaches are on you it's
because they expect a lot out of you
because they see it within you
you gotta find it and deliver that so
who are the toughest players to coach up
on special teams the the the big man on
campus I'm gonna give you two choices
the big man on campus who were drafted
later than they ever dreamt that they
would be drafted they thought they're a
big man on campus and it's tough to have
them do it or somebody who scams their
way into being a long snapper through
the magic of video editing interesting
like you John I'm trying to like with
all I can relate scenario you know
because you you kind of scammed your
well your first magic trick I didn't
lose lawful in this thing okay because I
had some okay so my thing was this is I
was a long snapper in high school and
then I went to a junior college they
were own four we went own forty right so
the longest losing streak in college
football
not a lot of coaches recruiting it on 40
school so I needed tape so I put my
highlight tape together
I had a dude named Nick Highland we
rotated look we're both white guys who
knew the difference there's no HD knows
no internet so I took his crushing hits
and I threw just some of them on my
highlight tape now it's great then we
had this guy Tim Thurmond better snapper
then then I probably ever was and I just
I borrowed some of his snapping tape and
I knew I could do it cuz I did it years
prior and I had somebody you know it is
what it is so the bottom line is I sent
it out I just need an opportunity right
so let's let let's relate these two
characters you got the first round big
fish yeah and then you got a guy like me
you know I was fortunate to play the
dude named London Fletcher who is never
missed a snap one of the greatest
players ever and I will never forget
yeah we're in a special teams meeting
special teams aren't going real well and
our kickoff return now this is back in
the day when you can set the old-school
wedge where five guys with linked arms
I was just concussion City I know it's
like in the middle of the field was
right now it was that's why they stopped
it do you remember a fullback named Sam
- of course okay so it's him and Sam gal
could you forget fact named - right
exactly as you possibly forget that and
all he would do is he'd look at you and
go uh-huh a big man you feel like
hitting today no no I actually I don't
say not at all and so so here's what
happens like we're a couple games into
the season now here's two studs to
established superstars on your team
right they walk into our special teams
meeting the two guys that would set the
wedge they said you guys are out we're
setting this thing you know cuz you guys
aren't getting the job done so these
guys walk in all the
these are the guys that aren't playing
special teams the superstars that you
know they're not doing the dirty work
they come in they volunteer for the job
they set the wedge Tarrance me he takes
it 100 yards for a touchdown Sam -
knocks a dude out I'll never forget he
looks to the sideline and all it plays
you know still going on he hits the guy
guy falls and he just looks at the
sideline and goes trainer big dude down
he don't want to hit you know London
Fletcher hits two three guys and keeps
going so I was fortunate to be around
teams and teammates that they did
whatever they had to do right and that
starts from the top when you got
superstars like London Fletcher setting
the tone that there was no job too big
or too small yeah but he's kind of
in-between what I was right he was a
small school guy what was London drafted
I don't think so I don't think Soph the
top of my head we I don't think so no
I'm the agent because I think his name
comes up a lot with one of the greatest
writers also about in terms of best
players that were undrafted Rod Smith of
the Denver Broncos as a guy we need to
start you know incorporating some long
snappers in charge
snapped a free agent of 2003 right here
on the Rich Eisen show and you know
that's the neat part about it's what I
love having you on John is that football
is just a small part of your story as a
matter of fact it's just a platform
that's allowed you to have the success
that you're having as well as the
stories that you are sharing and the way
that you share them again through a book
called life is magic my inspiring
journey from tragedy to self-discovery I
know a format like this with you know a
five or six minute window is not enough
to explain but I guess let's start with
why you decided to write this what's the
inspiration about this a lot of people
were hitting me up saying you got to
write a book to help people and I
finally realized what my journey was
about and moments before my daughter was
born which this was just like six months
ago I realized it was time for me to sit
down with my dad my dad murdered my mom
when I was 12 I went into a temporary
foster situation for a year before my
Aunt Susan adopted me intense therapy
and my life spent about trying to find
happiness and trying to find forgiveness
for me and for a long time I thought
forgiveness was about winning and losing
I thought it meant that hey one up we're
good scores even I agree with what you
did and we can still be buddies and then
before my daughter was born I realized
that I need to find motivation in the
worst
never happened to me to motivate change
to become a better father and a better
husband than I even thought I could so I
went and I sat down with my dad for the
first time in 26 years no kidding I had
lunch with him we're up in Washington
State is that where he yeah that's where
he lives he says he out of fries out oh
yeah so he's been out longer than he was
in so in Washington at the time
second-degree murder max penalty was 13
years so he was sentenced to 13
second-degree murder served 11 so he'd
been out longer and he was in and for me
what I realized is forgiveness I just
redefined what it means it means coming
to terms with my reality coming to terms
of my peace and getting rid of hate and
clutter and having somebody that's no
longer in my life have any effect on my
life whatsoever so I didn't eval adacia
I didn't need answers I didn't need
stories or excuses in fact it was
nothing to do with him so I went and I
sat down with him to look at him and to
feel that entire time of my life all
over again to realize what the
relationship of a father-son should be
and could have been and take all that
negativity and realized that that's the
exact opposite of what I'm gonna be for
my daughter Wow and I wrote about it and
so for me having lunch with my dad it's
symbolic of a relationship that was
betrayal and hurt and turning that into
motivation and so the the dedication in
the book mm-hmm it says to my baby my
baby girl Maya may you always have lunch
with your daddy and that means far more
than just sitting down and having lunch
yes straight yeah and as you know you
have a daughter and we were just talking
about it it changed my life and I don't
ever want to even remember my life
before my little girl and before I met
my wife and it's a the ultimate joy it's
true people without kids feel bad for
people with kids and then people with
kids feel bad for people without kids
because there's a joy and a love that
you just can't you can't explain and as
you know your little girl you were
talking about the Monday Night Football
and just sit and watch it and she's
writing a note that makes me complicit
and writing a note about how I stink but
no I mean and but the bond obviously
between parent and child is is something
that is usually unshakable unbreakable
what is your relationship with your dad
now do you have one at all no you know
because I realized that that journey for
me to go see him wasn't about that okay
it was about me finding peace and me
finding motivation to be a better dad
and the reason I went to go see him was
to relive that and you know part was
curiosity and
I'd been thinking about seeing him for a
long time but there was nothing in my
life that actually stemmed action mm-hmm
and then moments there was weeks before
my daughter was born I looked at my wife
and said it's time got to do it I got to
do it now is the time and would your
wife sir she was all for it
and she's like hey I support you and do
you want me there and I said this is
something I just want to Frank I just
wanna do alone and partly because I
wanted a few days just to process and it
took months like literally I had a new
emotion all day every day for months
about what that was and what that meant
and it was intense so I write about I
write about it in the book and and
what's really cool is when I reflect on
it it's it's things I learned in sports
and family and and how I prepared to go
meet my dad ironically was was the
disciplines I learned throughout all my
coaches and how to stay on track and how
to achieve something and how to have
discipline and process and I literally
treated it like a game plan which I know
sounds corny no I mean but but it worked
well it's a way that you've you've I
guess handled your business for most of
your life so sometimes you go with what
you know and that also means about
emotions too man oh yeah you know and
that's that's why it's so tough to go in
a different direction yeah and I realize
that I read a quote that if it's not you
know if it's easy you ain't growing and
so I wanted to take the road less
traveled at wanted to meet their fathers
or mothers that were estranged and then
they either passed away or they just
never did right and so I wanted to take
the road less traveled and I didn't
think I'd have any regrets doing it I
knew it would be hard and emotional and
it was and it was super intense but a if
it's easy you're not growing so take the
hard road and find happiness whatever
you got to do and if there's anybody
who's hearing this or watching this that
this sounds similar to something you've
been through or know somebody or it's
any way shape or form can be used to
help out your life life is magic my
inspiring journey from tragedy to
self-discovery John Doran Boston area or
the deck of cards on the cover where can
people see you perform
go to John Dornbos com I just finished a
little tour that we had now we're kind
of planning the next one so my website's
got everything at John Dornbos on social
and a life is magic and it's it's what
you make of it it's the words you tell
yourself so be careful what you tell
yourself be careful where you're going
and you know I hope everybody can find
closure in their life and find
forgiveness and peace and rock on
and there's Ellen DeGeneres with a quote
on the front yeah which is pretty cool I
mean they they end up calling me and say
hey I don't I don't know she's ever done
that before so when when she did that it
was it meant a lot it was super cool hey
not everybody can get quotes on the back
of their book from Ellen DeGeneres Garth
Brooks and Andy Reid really cool thanks
quite the triple play yeah and for me
Andy Reid has been a I still talk to him
I love him more than anything he was
such a great coach I was a big fan of
Garth Brooks and and we became friends
which is insane to even think about you
know when these people are like hey I'd
love to be a part of this you just kind
of set back and go whoa
like I was like I was a car a kid
shuffling cards you know back when I was
12 years old and now you're able to
collaborate with some of the greatest
people in the world it's really cool
Congrats John and you know this place is
welcome to any time you're 10 of spades
is in the front or as a count way corner
you know what if I write another book
yes I'm gonna call you out right now
okay I want to quote from Rich Eisen on
the back of John you know done it's
absolutely you're hearing it first right
here so I gotta write it I'm assuming
this is gonna be a paperback version
yeah like we can add one move over L&D
in a Garth I've got something pithy to
say for John Doerr embosses a paperback
version of life is magic you can follow
John are both Twitter Instagram at John
darn boss thanks for coming on thank you
guys love it whenever you come on thanks
really
Booker McFarlane still to come your
phone calls as well don't go anywhere
we're back on the Rich Eisen show in
just a minute for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app